Українські соцмережі бурхливо обговорюють
заклик президента Володимира Зеленського
до громадян не мовчати про факти корупції
й повідомляти про них на гарячу лінію НАБУ.
Президент запевнив, що правоохоронці будуть
реагувати на всі повідомлення і карати винних.
Мовляв, лише так можна буде зажити "по-іншому, чесно і за законом".
"Якщо від вас вимагають хабар,
пропонують відкат
чи будь-яку іншу корупційну схему - не мовчіть.
Не потрібно писати у соцмережах:
"Всьо пропало. Ці такі самі, як ті.
Зеленський понаставив своїх "рєшал".
Ні. Ось телефон.
Це гаряча лінія НАБУ. Дзвоніть і повідомляйте!"
У відповідь на заклик Зеленського
Рада громадського контролю НАБУ закликала президента
не поширювати дезінформацію, адже далеко не кожен
корупційний випадок підпадає під повноваження
Національного антикорупційного бюро.
DW з'ясувала, що слід знати українцям, які
зіткнулися з випадками корупції, і куди їм зрештою звертатися.
Детективи НАБУ займаються
кримінальними корупційними правопорушеннями,
які вчинені вищими посадовими особами, тобто
топ-чиновниками державного або місцевого рівня,
і можуть становити загрозу національній безпеці.
Якщо конкретно, то НАБУ розслідує корупційні справи,
до яких причетні народні депутати, прем’єр-міністр,
члени Кабінету міністрів, керівництво Нацбанку, Фонду держмайна,
президент України, повноваження якого припинено,
держслужбовці, посада яких належить до категорії "А",
судді, прокурори тощо.
Окрім високопосадовців, під юрисдикцію НАБУ
підпадають чиновники, розмір заподіяної шкоди якими
дорівнює або перевищує 500 прожиткових мінімумів,
а це приблизно 960 тисяч гривень.
Тобто якщо хабар вимагає лікар, директор школи чи працівник ЖЕКу,
не варто одразу дзвонити в НАБУ.
Цим займаються інші правоохоронні органи.
Профільні міністерства та відомства мають
свої відділи з боротьби з корупцією та телефони гарячих ліній,
за якими можна звертатися, аби повідомити про корупційні злочини.
Наприклад, про вимагання хабаря в лікарні
слід повідомляти на гарячу лінію Національної служби здоров’я України.
Щодо протиправних дій поліцейського - до Нацполіції.
Контакти відповідних органів слід шукати
на офіційних сайтах установ. Також
щодо випадків корупції можна дзвонити
до Державного бюро розслідувань та Служби безпеки України.
Через хибну інформацію про повноваження бюро
гаряча лінія НАБУ буде перевантажена дзвінками
щодо порушень, які непідслідні антикорупційному бюро,
вважають у Раді громадського контролю НАБУ.
Заклик президента може дестабілізувати роботу НАБУ
та викликати негативне ставлення серед населення,
адже через незнання статей КПК громадяни
вимагатимуть від НАБУ реагувати і розслідувати справи, які йому непідслідні.
У Раді громадського контролю НАБУ порадили Зеленському:
якщо він хоче допомогти правоохоронним органам
у боротьбі з корупцією, варто розглянути питання
універсальної гарячої лінії для повідомлень про корупційні правопорушення.